Yo! I'm Daniel and if this is your first
time here on my channel WELCOME to my channel!
Consider subscribing and also clicking the notification bell so you won't miss any
of the next videos. Now this is a video
request. A lot of you guys asked me to
give you skincare tips on how to get
clear skin so I'm gonna give you guys 7
tips to get healthy clear skin. Let's not
waste any more time.
Let's get right in to the video!
All right, now we're not girls, right? So
we don't need to do a thousand things to
get healthy and clear skin, but there are
a few things, a few habits that you need
to pick up on and do to get and maintain
healthy clear skin. So let's start with
the first one.
In the age that we live in
it's pretty common sense but you need to
eat a healthier food. Most research shows that the food you eat impacts not only
your face but your overall appearance as
well. So food rich in vital nutrients
like vitamins, key minerals, omega fatty
acids, fish oil, protein and antioxidants
will help your skin to look better. Think
about it if you eat crap you're gonna
get crap. I'll make a dedicated video for
you guys about the best food that you
can eat for your skin but just to
mention a few you gotta eat more healthy
vegetables, nuts, fatty fish, avocado seeds, sweet potatoes, soy and stay away from
sugar, bad oils, bad carbs like bread and
actually most unhealthy processed foods
Alright let's move on
You're probably doing it right now... stop
touching your face. I got a few guys, right? Yeah, you got to
stop touching your face. I mean through
the day you pick up a lot of germs and
then you touch your face all over with
that dirty hands and then it goes into
your pores and that's not what you want.
Think about it: What do you do with your
hands the whole day? Well almost
everything right and how many times do
you wash it? Yeah... that's another tip you
can wash your hands a little bit more
All right let's move on to the next tip.
You probably know this already but you got
to drink more water. Wait a second... Why
do you need to drink more water?
Well, drinking around 8 glasses of water a day will help your body to get rid of those
toxins and anything else that shouldn't
be there.
A man's skin just like a woman's
needs daily care to look clean and healthy as the years go by. You don't need
hundreds of products but you do
need a basic skin care routine that
doesn't take a lot of time and effort.
First you need a good water-soluble
cleanser that will clean your face from all
that oil and the dirt that you've been
picking up throughout the day or when
you wake up in the morning, you sleep and
your body produces sebum and it produces oil and it blocks your pores, so you need
to wash it. You need to wash all that
gunk off. Then after the face wash you'll
also need a good moisturizer that will
really give your skin what it needs to
stay fresher, smoother and hydrated as
well but to get a better result you need
a nice exfoliating toner.
You got to use it right in between the facial wash and moisturizer
(Steps: 1. face wash 2. exfoliating toner  3. moisturizer).
It makes a huge
difference because it (exfoliating toner) removes all those
dead skin cells that clog your pores and
it reduce the pores as well and the
redness if you use the right exfoliating
toner. So it's very important to use the
right skin care products because there's,
oh my goodness, there's a lot of products
out there that's actually very bad for
your skin. Products of drying ingredients
like menthol, denatured alcohol as well as skin aggravating ingredients like peppermint,
witch hazel and eucalyptus so what are
the best products out there that you can
trust? Well I've tried a lot of products
over the years but by far my most
favorite is PC4MEN.  It's a trusted
brand that brings much needed honesty
into the skincare world. If you get it
you'll get good results, but there's also
other options like Clinique, Rugged and
Dapper, Tiege Hanley and Brickell and just
like always I've added those products
for you in a video description so it's
easier for you to go and check them out
and do your own research. Never ever just
believe whatever a youtuber says. That's
why I add those links for you guys in
the description, so you can go and do your own research. Read the customer reviews
on them as well. Alright let's move on to
the next one
Sleep! You got to get more sleep
I've also said this in a few other
videos but if you look like dehydrated
and kind of dull it's a big sign that
you need more sleep. When you sleep your
body starts to repair itself more and
that includes your face as well. Try to
get around 7 to 9 hours of sleep. If you
get less than 6 it's definitely gonna
affect your appearance
You gotta stop popping and just
scratching at those pimples, especially
if they're big and if they are swollen. You
don't want to do that especially if you
don't know how and when to do it. Why?
Well because they can cause acne marks
and worse permanent scars. Now I get it
sometimes you have that special event
and then you have a huge zit/pimple here and it's ugly and huge and it just came
at the wrong time and then you're gonna
pop it and you're not gonna listen to me
or anybody else, right? But there's a way
to do it. Maybe I'll make a video a
dedicated video for you guys on how to
do it and at the right time as well. But
using a good skin care routine will
really help you out and you'll get a lot
less pimples but now and then with
stress and a lot of things you might get
the odd pimple or two now, but if you struggle and if you have very bad acne I'll add a
few good products for you new video
description down below that will really
help you out
Stress less. Yes, you got to stress less
because stress creates a lot of problems
if you stress your body creates these
hormones like cortisol and that can
create pimples and even worse breakouts
so find ways that will help you to
stress less and learn how to cope better with different situations that might give you
more stress. Remember 99% of the things
that we think will happen never happens
and it's not the stress that brings you
down, but it's your reaction to that
stress. If you liked the video give it a
thumbs up subscribe and I'll see you in
the next video
cheers guys